hello so baby number three is on the way
yeah my wife is gonna love that intro
yeah she should be a little scared I
always think like because I have two
well I'm outnumbered because I'm single
now but like but it's a different thing
when you're outnumbered you're like no
one's there to like you know you only
have so many arms yes everyone says like
on the first baby they're like oh
congratulations the second baby they're
like congratulations on the survey
there's like a question mark at the end
yeah congratulations
um where should I send the flower yeah
but uh we're excited my wife is uh let
me just take this moment on National
Television to say how beautiful amazing
she is
that's exciting though it is cool like
your family's just getting even bigger
that's cool yeah check in with me in
about yeah and you're gonna be like when
you're tired yeah it is siblings like I
have two
me to have another baby they get excited
they want a baby in the house that's
like how I wanted my parents to get a
dog so bad and I was like I will
participate like I will walk the dog
yeah I don't see that I did nothing no
the whole I think I walked that dog one
time my daughter suckered me into that
as well I think she prepped me if you
should have a baby and I was like oh
she was like
or I was like okay okay so we got
another one and she said she'd help and
she lied as a parent though are you Pro
um like screen time are you like Pro
that or like are you trying to you know
Steer clear of it we're trying to do as
little screen time as possible we were
real like no screen time people that's
how we all start yeah exactly yeah and
then you're like I need to pee
exactly
um wait did your parents let you have
screen time did you watch TV no I am a
uh product of
it was not zero screen time my mom loved
old movies yeah
another wonderful woman I'd love to
shout out and uh she only let me watch
classic movies which sounds like a good
move and was ultimately great that I
wasn't watching a lot of TV but I only
watched old movie I liked a lot of uh
Cary Grant a lot of Danny K yeah but I
would go into school and like one time
like in seventh grade I used the term
man alive which is like a you know some
bad happens you're a man alive in like
the 40s
and I I started to realize like TV is
like how you normalize people they get
to know like how what the vernacular is
like now yeah and so I went to boarding
school uh when I was a teenager and then
I watched TV for like three years
non-stop to catch up to catch up and say
oh this is how people you're right
modern day talk right yeah I think
you're right that that is like how
friendships like you talk about the same
thing you have this oh did you see that
episode when this happened that you're
true all the kids are saying yeah did
you see a Living Color did you see yeah
Saturday live yeah I had no idea what
they were talking about and then and
then I just like binged uh everything
that had ever been made once I was away
but anyway my mom was wonderful I'm glad
she did it I think she had great taste
is what that is yeah actually I didn't
tell her this is uh my mom told me that
uh Saltines were cookies
oh
okay Poor Man's Dessert you'd have like
a little butter and like a marshmallow
and you'd put it in the microwave and it
was like dessert
yeah my mom just thought like I mean she
had all the right idea she was like
let's keep these kids healthy and so she
I'd have a cookie please and she can be
a saltina's yum and then
and then when I was like six or
something I went on my first sleepover
to a kid's house and this kid was like
that's not a cookie
this is a it was like an Oreo and I was
like what is that and I she had to come
pick me up because I couldn't sleep like
yeah I had so much sugar in myself like
the whole thing of Oreos yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]